welcome back and we never let you down I
said as soon as we find out we would
share it with you this is a tweet that
just came out ESP and sources save the
NBA is suspending golden states Draymond
Green indefinitely and before we had
this discussion I looked up indefinitely
because I know we're going to talk about
it it means unlimited or
unspecified period of time so if you're
an optimist that sounds great but if
you're a pessimist it could be really a
long time what do you think
Jamal I think it'll be somewhere in the
middle I I think you know it it gives
him time to really look at it and figure
it out but
also the history is going to work
against him I believe in the situation
and and something just happened last
month in the past we see the objections
I think that part of it will work
against him in the situation this is the
first i' been in around the league a
long time this is the first for me I
mean maybe it's been before um I played
in the David Stern era it been some
harsh you know suspensions came out but
inde definitely for me my definition
says
forever that sounds different when you
say indefinitely Your Dictionary is you
know Webster mine is out of Detroit
that's yours is Saints City forever and
I I I think right now just on a serious
note this is something that's concerning
when you hear that and it rightfully so
but I think this will get draymond's
attention the Warriors attention the
League's Attention our attention um this
this is something I haven't seen before
so and I agree with you I was um alarmed
at the word choice right uh the use of
the word indefinitely because it is open
for interpretation which is why I
brought up the actual definition of it
my question to you because Smitty you've
been around a long time in this league
you've been behind some closed
doors do you think that there
are strings attached to this meaning do
you think he's going to have to fulfill
some some things in order to get back on
the court whether it be right sure and I
don't know what they are right but I
would say step you you hit it right on
yes we can come out and say yes because
when you say inde definitely until we
hear more correct there's going to be
some steps or like you process something
that has to happen but I also say being
around here you have to be careful with
the lead because yes because if you
start to say indefinitely for history or
you saying indefinitely because of the
acttion incident the incident we've seen
before and somebody do it two times in a
row will they be indefinitely um and I
understand this is history but it
definitely is a long time for
potentially potentially potentially a
long time yeah and I think also because
the league did come out publicly and
state the last time that history
definitely plays a part in the sentence
if you will the consequence I think
that's where we are with Draymond Green
unfortunately for
him